politics is suddenly ripping this
country apart on college campuses
students attack free speech in the name
of tolerance civil rights activists have
abandoned there were the old causes to
obsess over abstractions like global
warming in this once Christian country
leaders are now demanding that we bomb
Bashar al-assad endangering the lives of
the world's oldest Christian community
we'll hit all of those issues tonight
plus there eating horse meat in parts of
this country amazingly but we're gonna
start with the FBI's efforts to spy on
the Trump campaign back in 2016 that
happened there's a lot more evidence for
it than there is for collusion with
Russia but not surprisingly the media
response has been predictably dishonest
here's a selection Trump doubles down on
his baseless claims of spies its
so-called spy issue first of all there's
absolutely no evidence there was a spy
so it's really a fake issue this phony
baloneys story about a spy on the
campaign to call them a conspiracy
theory is to give them too much credit
just fake facts they're liars Senator
Lindsey Graham of South Carolina as
reliable a barometer of mindless
conventional wisdom as exists on planet
Earth explained it this way in a recent
interview quote a confidential informant
is not a spy well senator Graham did not
explain what exactly a confidential
informant is if not a spy because of
course they're one in the same a
confidential informant is someone who is
informing confidentially
in other words spying any senator who
pretends otherwise is prevaricated
in other words lying damageno has been
following the Russia story since the
very beginning he's a former Secret
Service agent and a contributor at NRA
TV Danny better in law enforcement your
whole life if I'm confidentially
informing on you what am i doing exactly
Tucker this is the most of a series of
sickening disgusting disturbing episodes
by the Pravda no no they're not even
problem you know because problem that
was at least honest about being
dishonest
the problem media now pretends that
their actual journalists distributing
facts keep in mind Tucker they want to
do counterintelligence these people they
can't even do journalism now they're
pretending to be counterintelligence and
law enforcement
this is the most dangerous cover-up by
the media I have ever seen every serious
person in law I said serious by the way
in law enforcement that I know not the
hacks out there trying to cover for this
knows what happened here was a spying
operation as py SP why why if you're Joe
Biden this was a spying operation period
like anybody tells you otherwise is
joking well telling us you're wise
they're all telling us otherwise which
is why I'm beginning to doubt myself I'm
open-minded
tell me sincerely am I missing something
they're saying it wasn't a spy it was a
confidential informant is there some
difference that I'm missing yes there is
Tucker but the difference works against
the Pravda media not for these jokers
okay here's how we would commonly and in
the law enforcement intelligence arena
where I had intersected and worked for
most of my adult life it would work an
informant is actually someone already
existing inside of an operation we would
inform on the operations of said
operation the mob whatever it may be a
spy would likely be someone you bring in
who is not a pre-existing member of the
operation you try to insert and
intersect with that organization to get
information to either prosecute them or
investigate them on a CI case which
means the guy in this case was a spy
these knuckleheads are our Tucker you
understand this is full-blown propaganda
I do it let me see what's happening
either way the persons function is the
same he's spying he's gathering
information not telling you that he's
doing it and sending it to a third party
by the way if this was done and again
I'm asking dumb rhetorical questions
just because they keep throwing this at
you like black is white two plus two
equals eight I just want to make sure I
got this right if they were doing this
for the benefit of the Trump campaign as
clapper is now claiming wouldn't they
have told the Trump campaign hey we're
worried that the Russians are trying to
penetrate you but they didn't well
Tucker if this was for the benefit of
the Trump campaign why not equally
assist in
support the Hillary campaign right I
mean Hillary's husband had taken five
hundred thousand dollars into speaking
free from a Russian bank why not equally
the dreaded air quotes here help them to
and put an FBI human it's a scam I mean
what what's in it Tucker the euphemism
game what is it next going to be an
undocumented FBI employee this is so
destructive because the American people
Liberal Democrat whoever you are you
need to understand a gross disservice
was done here there were illegal leaks
and there was a potentially illicit
spying operation for political reasons
everybody for whoever you want to vote
for I don't care I'm just telling you
what happened here was an abomination to
the Republic and the media is covering
it up it's amazing that they're going
along it's one thing to see Nancy Pelosi
defend the indefensible that's what she
does but to see reporters a lot of whom
I know and I'm friends with have known a
long time they're lying about this I
actually find it shocking Dan thank you
for the clarity on that as always yes
sir